okay uh let's get started
uh my name is dan ha i'm associate
professor of
bioengineering at the university of
pennsylvania
and i'd like to start by thanking the
organizers of the meeting
for the opportunity to speak about our
work today
just as quick introduction let me start
by telling you a little bit about the
work that we do
in my research lab at penn so research
in my group
basically focuses on developing these
micro fabricated devices
that we use to grow human cells but we
also use these systems to
mimic complex structures and dynamic
environment of human tissues and organs
in ways
that have not been possible using
traditional cell culture
systems so here the idea is to use these
systems as microengineered models of
human tissues and organs for a variety
of applications
so these systems are collectively known
as
human organs on a chip and this term is
used synonymously with tissue chips
or microphysiological systems
so what i'd like to do today is to give
you a quick
introduction to this technology and
perhaps
help you better understand what this
technology
allows us to do using a several examples
of human organs on a chip
model systems we're developing in my lab
so if you're new to this technology
perhaps
one of the first questions you could ask
is how do we actually make organ chips
how do we
how do you go about designing and
creating uh
these advanced in vitro systems so let
me
spend just a couple of minutes talking
about the design principles and that we
use
so obviously you'd have to have a target
organ and for this discussion
let's say we're interested in modeling
the lung
so the first step in this design process
is to closely
examine the anatomy of the target organ
and identify the functional unit
responsible for
organ-specific physiological functions
so in the lung that would be the
alveolar system
shown here and the next step is to
closely examine the uh
the functional unit to identify the key
features
uh that you want to replicate in your
engineered system
so we often start this process by
looking at the structure
so if you look at the alveolar capillary
interface
in the lung there is a thin layer of
alveolar epithelial tissue on one side
another thin layer of capillary
endothelial cells on the other side
and these two layers are separated by a
thin interstitial
and we also pay close attention to the
environment
of the functional unit so what's unique
about the alveolar system is that
there's a blood flow through the
capillary blood vessels
surrounding the alveolar sacs and these
air sacs expand and contract
during respiration so once you
identify those key features the next
step is to design
a microfluidic device that would allow
you to
mimic those essential features
so this is actually a human breathing
law on a chip
system that we published many years ago
this is actually the photo of the device
if you look at the cutaway view of the
device
there are two cell culture chambers uh
separated by
thin force membrane so in this system we
culture human lung cells and capillary
cells on either side of the membrane to
mimic the structure of the alveolar
capillary
interface we also use these hollow
vacuum channels to stretch
the tissue layers to mimic breathing
motions in this man-made
microfluidic device so we can
use these kinds of systems to mimic the
structural organization of
multiple tissue types in the functional
unit of the target organ but
what's more interesting and exciting is
that by having these
multiple cell types and tissue types
talk to each other
we can start thinking about making more
complex
integrated organ level functions and
responses
so to help you better understand what
i'm talking about here
let's actually think about lung
infection as an example so during lung
infection let's say these bacteria
actually make it all the way down to the
alveolar sacs and one of the interesting
things that they do
that they do there is to stimulate
alveolar epithelial tissue to produce
and secrete inflammatory cytokines shown
as
green spheres in this animation and they
actually diffuse into the surrounding
blood vessel tissues and they reach the
blood vessels
and what they do is actually they
activate endothelial cells in the
surrounding
capillaries so when this happens i
use this movie to help engineers to
better understand
this process so these white cells like
neutrophils circulating in the blood
as you know they have the ability to
recognize these
surface receptors expressed by the
active endothelial cells
so what they do is they actually stick
to the
activated endothelial tissue and they
transmigrate
uh through the endothelium into the
alveolar sacs and once inside the air
sex
they start crawling directly towards the
side of infection
via chemotaxis and when they get there
they try to resolve the infection by
engulfing and phagocytosing the
bacterial cells
so this is uh basically how our lung
fights of infection
and as far as i know this is one of the
most complex oracle level not tissue
level organ
level responses that happens in in the
lump
so the question we asked was uh can we
actually mimic this in this
long on a chip system so
what we did was uh we actually put
fluorescently attacked the human
neutrophils into the lower capillary
channel
as you can see here nothing interesting
happens
but when in the presence of bacterial
cells on the lung surface
these neutrophils now stick presumably
because these
endothelial cells are now activated and
this movie
shows the entire process so this
neutrophil as you can see here
sticks first and then it curls around at
some point it starts wiggling its way
through the
capillary cells and one of the
pentagonal pores on the membrane to get
across the
three tissue layers from the lower
compartment to the upper chamber
and once inside the uh in the lung
chamber these white cells are shown in
red here
uh change the bacteria and phagocytosis
just like what happens
in the living human law so we can not
only mimic the entire
process but we can also visualize
and analyze this very complex uh
process in real time at high resolution
so this was the proof of concept
demonstration of building complex organ
chip
systems published 10 years ago so
jumping in time
you might be wondering what's happening
now so one of the major trends in the
field of organs and trips is to develop
disease models and used these
specialized models for a variety of
biomedical applications including drug
testing
so just to give you a couple examples of
the lung disease models we're building
in my lab
as you can tell from this slide we're
actually developing one on a chip
system to study adverse health effects
of cigarette smoking
so we have a very specific goal of
investigating
what happens in small areas deep in the
lung during
smoking associated or induced
lung injuries and diseases so for those
who are new to this
this is what humans malaria tissue
typically looks like
the tissue consists of the columnar
epithelium supported by this
stroma containing stromal cells like
fibroblast
interstitial macrophages and also blood
vessels
so to mimic this multi-layered
architecture
we actually came up with this uh
multi-layered
microfluidic device consisting of five
layers
so this is work done by mark mondrinos
who is now professor at tulane
university
so to mimic this uh strumming layer
uh what we do is we fill this middle uh
chamber with
type 1 collagen gel mixed with human
lung fibroblasts
and this layer is then sandwiched
between these two chambers
uh lined with primary hemosphere
epithelial cells and lung
microvascular endothelial cells so using
the system we
culture especially this these area
epithelial cells under air to induce
differentiation this is a micrograph of
a fully differentiated epithelium that
contains cilia and also they form tight
junctions
and we also came up with the way to
embed
these fibroblasts and culture them for
long periods of time
without the the detachment or shrinkage
of the gel
and as you can see here these
fibroblasts actually are sitting in the
gel
and the starting material is collagen
and we're actually staining uh
ecm fibronectin is produced and secreted
by
these fibroblasts so we have evidence
that these cells
start remodeling their surrounding
matrices
in this microfluidic device so this is
the setup that we use to expose the
cells to cigarette smoke
we use off-the-shelf computer control
the cigarette smoking machine that
generates
a mainstream cigarette smoke that gets
humidified and diluted
more than 96 percent to mimic the look
concentrations
uh deep in the lung and the diluted
sample is delivered to the
smoking wellness system so the important
question is
what can we study using the system so
there are a variety of endpoints we can
measure and analyze but in the interest
of time
let me show you one interesting
observation we made in this model
so just to refresh your memory this is
what this formal tissue looks like
with these fibroblasts sitting in the
gel and green
green shows green color shows uh cell to
positive fibronectin
so in one of the experiments we actually
smoked the cells with one cigarette a
day
for one week and two weeks and one month
and this is actually what we saw we saw
a very significant increase in number of
fibroblasts as well as
ecm deposition and in many cases we saw
these very intense cellular nodules
and with a lot of ecm deposition around
these cells
so this is actually if you think about a
typical fibrotic response
so this is nothing new uh you know
aortic fibrosis has been
a common pathophysiological feature of
disease to lungs in chronic smokers and
lung cancer patients
but it was very interesting to be able
to model this injury induce the fibrotic
response
in this organ on a chip system
in the interest of time i'm going to
have to skip over this but we have we
studied also adverse health defects of
electronic cigarettes
using this system
so here's another uh example of lung
disease model we're developing in the
lab
so in this case we're modeling cancer
immunotherapy
for lung cancer so with the support from
the
cancer resistance research institute
we've been working over the past three
years
to engineer a system that would allow us
to mimic
immune cell cancer interactions
in the context of cancer immunotherapy
so in this project one of the first
things we had to do was to engineer
refusable human blood vessels and this
is the device that we use to do that
and uh this is a cutaway view of the
device so what's interesting here is the
fact that
there are these two barriers protruding
from the ceiling of the channel
so you use these barriers to trap liquid
in the middle lane
of this device so liquid is injected
into this middle lane it
nicely follows the lane it never spills
over
over to the set lanes because it gets
pinned along these barriers due to
surface tension
so this capillary pinning effect is
demonstrated in this movie where
black foot coloring is injected into the
central channel
there's a little bit of bulging but it
never spills over to the satellites
so using this technique we inject
hydrogel solution mixed with fibroblasts
and
endothelial cells and we
culture them in the hydrogel and during
culture
endothelial cells in this in the in the
hydrogel
assemble themselves into 3d vessels that
open to the side
channels so this vasculogenic process
is uh visualized in this movie where if
you look at this middle compartment
uh filled with uh red fluorescent entire
cells
over time you can see them develop a 3d
vascular structure in the hydrogel
scaffold
so this takes about five to seven days
and at the end of this
uh vasculogenic process uh the
endothelial cells
uh form these beautiful uh tubular
structures
and you can see these fibroblasts wrap
around these tubes
as if there are pericytes and these
vessels have open lumens as you can see
in this
section and we've also developed a
technique
uh to extract these uh vascularized
tissue constructs as a whole
after we formed them so these examples
can be further processed for imaging
this is a scan electron micrograph of a
single micro vessel
in the hydrogel scaffold we can do tem
so this is a tm image of a single
capillary which is very similar
to individual vessels and and we also
have the ability to tune the
architecture of
these blood vessels so depending on how
many cells you put in how many how stiff
the gel is
these are all the same type of
endothelial cells but they show very
different architecture
during culture and this micrograph
shows anastomosis of endothelial lining
in the side channels with the 3d vessels
in the gel
so as a result of anastomosis the
vessels open to the side channels and
the whole network
becomes perfusable as you can see in
this movie so this movie shows a
fluorescent
dye flowing through the vessels uh
and it's it's also possible to flow
microbes and nanoparticles for
for example targeted drug delivery
applications
uh we've also tested flowing uh blood
cells
red blood cells on the right on the left
and
t cells actually in this case they are
migrating uh
in the tnf treated vessels and you can
see all different sorts of behaviors
t-cell behaviors in this movie
so we're now using this as a platform to
build more realistic
3d human tissues so just to very quickly
walk you through some of the examples
we've developed the vascularized human
eyelid on a chip
system shown here where we
put these cadaveric eyelets actually we
receive from donors
into our device we vascularize and we
can maintain their function
for over a month actually without any
loss of viability functionality
we can also induce adipogenesis and
vasculogenesis at the same time to
model white adipose tissue
and this is a micrograph of a tumor
construct that we got
we got from our collaborator scout
warden
at chop uh and we were able to
vascularize these uh patient tumor
explants in our device
and maintain um this tumor tissue for
long periods of time
so what we do is we chop these tumeric
plants into small pieces we put them
into our device along with
fibroblasts and endothelial cells and
over time they form these vascularized
tumor constructs
in the hydrogel scaffold as you can see
in this
confocal movie the vessels are formed in
and around the vest
and in around the tumor constructs
and because the vessels are perfusable
the tumor
constructs also become perfusable
and this is another platform uh where we
actually create this open top
uh and so in this system the first thing
we do is do
we put in the uh this insert we form the
vessels following the same protocol
when tumor actually samples that are you
know
not easy to get become available
we get bring these tumor tissues
open the open up the the compartment
and put the tumor constructs into the
chamber into the hydrogel
and we vascularize them so the nice
thing about this design is that
we get to determine where the tumor
tissues end up in this
device and this is what the tumor tissue
looks like right after we put it
into uh put them into our wells and this
is what they look like after a couple of
days of culture they
become vascularized very quickly and
again
we can use these profusable blood
vessels
in and around the tumors to flow cells
drugs you know different kinds of
materials for a variety of applications
so as i said we're using this as a
platform to study tumor immense cell
interactions and we have a lot of data
but
uh in the interest of time let me show
you that this is an interesting kind of
proof of concept study
that we conducted so this micrograph
shows a mesothelion over expressing a549
tumor spheroids and we were actually
able to vascularize these tumors ferrows
in our device
so we're now using this uh model system
to study
uh the efficacy of engineered immune
cells like carties
so in this movie uh these red cells are
cartes
engineered to recognize a mesothelion
expressed by the tumor
spheroids this is a couple of hours
after infusion
as you can see many of these tumors
cartes
adhere to the tumor associated vessels
and within
just a couple of days many of these t
cells infiltrate the tumor and they're
found within the tumor
and as a result of this t-cell
infiltration
we see we saw significant effect on the
growth of tumors
and we also have evidence that t cells
induce
apoptosis of cancer cells to exert tumor
killing effects
so we're now using this system to screen
uh
the the effects of different kinds of
engineered t-cells and we're also
delving into the molecular biology of
tumor cancer interactions this is uh
probably one of the most exciting but
challenging projects
we've worked on in the lab so we've also
sent those tissue chips organ chips up
to space
we got selected as one of the five labs
in the country
about three years ago to send those
tissue chips up to
the international space station so in
this project we're
studying immunosuppression which refers
to this interesting phenomena that
occurs in the microgravity environment
so it's known that for many years
that astronauts get sick more easily
during or right after space flight and
there's
some evidence that the microgravity
environment
compromises our immune function so
we're actually investigating this
interesting uh
space phenomenon uh using
our model systems so in this project
we're actually
creating a model of respiratory
infection which accounts for
more than 30 percent of all infections
that occur in astronauts and we're also
developing a human bone marrow on a chip
to
model the entire process of immune cell
recruitment
from the marrow to the infected organ
so we've developed airy
model and we've also established area
infection using a micro
model microorganism by pseudomonas and
we've also created the vascularized
human bone marrow
on a chip system using human
cd34 positive hematopoietic stem cells
and this system really allows us to
recapitulate the
the multicellular heterogenating
complexity of the human marrow
so using these systems actually uh we've
created this uh
credit card size device uh each
containing
six replicates of each organ so six
replicates of
ariana chip six replicas of bone marrow
and chipmunks away this is the device
actually we flew
last year so we uh the system was
sent up on the spacex crs 17 last year
and this is a photograph of the cube lab
that contained our experiments
up under stationed and we're in the
process of analyzing data and
using the samples that actually i
returned to earth last year
so um these are some of the examples of
the lung
disease models we're developing in the
in the lab but
if you think about it you know this is
not limited to modeling
uh what happens in the respiratory
system so we can use exactly the same
approach
to mimicking any other organs
in the human body on a chip so to give
an example of
such systems we are also modeling the
human eye
more specifically the front of the eye
called the ocular surface
so if you're new to this
the ocular surface as you probably know
consists of the cornea at the center
surrounded by the conjunctiva which
refers to this transparent tissue
covering the white part of the eye
conjunctival tissue is also found
underneath the eyelids
so if you look at the tissue structures
the corneal tissue
consists of this stratified epithelium
that has seven to eight layers and this
epithelium is
supported by this collagen rich stroma
that also contains the cells called the
cradocytes
these are normally quiescent stromal
cells
that live in the stromal tissue
and the conjunctival tissue contains
these goblet cells
that are responsible for producing mucus
which is one of the key components of
tears
another really interesting feature of
the ocular surface
is eye blinking shown in this animation
so as you can see here blinking x to
spread tears to form this thin
film on the ocular surface tissue
that serves to hydrate the tissue layer
and it also uh forms this a nice
smooth reflective surface for light
transmission so this is something we
found very interesting
from an engineering standpoint so to
mimic these
essential features uh we've created this
uh
micro engineered device that we call
the human blinking eye on a chip
so this work uh was done in
collaboration with the three
ophthalmologists at penn
uh shown here so this paper came out in
nature medicine last year so
if you're interested you can read more
about it and this is actually what the
entire device
looks like we use this uh 3d scaffold
highly porous scaffold
that looks like a context and so what we
do is we
to mimic these multi layered tissue
architecture
one of the first things we do is to
inject hydrogel
mixed with human primary human
carotosites into the cavities of the
scaffold
so this micrograph shows nice deep
penetration of the cells into the
scaffold
and we've also came up with the way to
deposit these two different cell types
in a physiologically relevant manner so
we can actually put down
corneal primary human corneal cells at
the center of the scaffold
and we can surround them with the
conjunctival cells to
form this concentric tissue pattern as
seen on the surface of the human eye
so during culture what we do is we first
to see the device we
keep everything immersed in culture
media we filled
the upper chamber with the media we flow
media
through the lower chamber as well but
once we form the tissue layer
confluent tissue layer on the surface of
the scaffold we aspirate liquid
from the upper chamber to expose the
cells to air
and we culture these cells at the air
liquid interface
to induce differentiation so during this
culture period
the cells are fed basically from the
media flowing in the fluorine chamber
so as a result of cell differentiation
as you can see here the corneal cells
that start off as a single layer
form multiple layers six to seven layers
and so basically they become
stratified they also form tight
cell cell junctions as you can see in
the sustaining of occluding which is one
of the
tight junction proteins and the marker
expressions so the cytokeratine 3 and 12
are terminal differentiation markers of
corneal epithelial cells
so as you can tell over time marker
expression increases but
it increases to a greater extent when
the cells are exposed to
air and these are more
uh interesting uh effects
or observations so initially the
cell surfaces are flat but as a result
of differentiation the corneal
epithelial cells form
these microstructures like microvilli
microplicae that are almost
indistinguishable from those features
from
seen on the surface of the human eye
we also confirmed that the some of these
conjunctival epithelial cells
during ali culture differentiate into
museum producing cells in our
device so once the cells are
differentiated
we use the system shown in this movie to
mimic blinking
so this is a gelatin hydrogel that we
use as a mimic
of the eyelid and we use this electro
electric motor to slide it back and
forth
to mimic blinking activities in
human eyes
so this is a close-up of the movie we
inject
contrived tears into this channel we
apply a little bit of pressure the fluid
comes out and gets picked up by this
sliding hydra eyelid and then gets
spread on the ocular surface
so the reason why we do this is to form
thin
film on the surface of the scaffold
we used oct to actually image the
terrafilm layer which is about six
microns and this is actually disposed
within the physiological range uh human
physiological theorem film thickness
ranges from five
uh all the way up to 10.
so i'll just skip this but we also did
some modeling to show the similarities
between human eyes and the iono chip in
terms of the biomechanics
initially we were concerned about cells
is sloughing off due to blinking but as
it turns out cells remain adherent and
viable on the surface and actually
help the cells to differentiate it much
more rapidly
as you can see in this expression of
cytokine 12
with them without that blinking we saw a
more rapid increase in the ck expression
in the presence of blinking in our model
system so based on this result
uh we speculate that the the mechanical
force is due to blinking
might be contributing to cell
differentiation and maintenance
of this tissue layer
so in this study we also use this plant
platform to model dry eye disease and in
the interest of time i'm going to have
to skip over this part
today but uh we basically use this
system to mimic evaporative type of
dry eye disease and i use the disease
model for
testing ophthalmic lubricant so i'm
happy to tell you more about this
offline if you're interested
and i want to just quickly mention that
we've been also doing a lot of work in
the area of
reproductive biology medicine so you
know we this is an area that has long
suffered from a lack of human relevant
predictive pre-clinical models and so
we're actually very excited about uh the
possibility of
contributing to this field using our
organization
so we published papers about plus
santana japan and cervix on what you
began
i'm happy to tell you more about these
model systems
if you're interested
so before i finish let me just spend one
a minute or two
to talk about a new direction the very
exciting new direction we've been
uh exploring over the past three years
or so
so uh hopefully you know i i was able to
convince you that organ to model systems
are great in that
they allow us to mimic the complexity of
human physiological systems
uh but the flip side is actually you
know it's not very easy to work with
these
systems it's a lot of work to develop
these model systems
it's also a lot of work to maintain
these tissue layers for long periods of
time
for experiments so for these technical
reasons
uh throughput experimental thrip and
typical organ ship
model systems is very low so i would say
this is
one of the most fundamental challenges
we as organ chip engineers fails
face in our field so we took this
problem to heart
and began to work on developing higher
throughput organs
technology and the way we do it is to
uh scale up by walking away from those a
single channel containing devices
and we have begun to use these plate
devices each containing tens of
replicates
and most recently we developed this uh
six inch wafer size device
that contains 128
individually addressable cell culture
chambers
which are regulated by very
sophisticated pneumatic circuits
and this movie shows individual
addressability
of these culture chambers shown on the
uh
left portion of this movie and we spent
a lot of time
on trying to automate the process of
manufacturing these chips
this device contains more than 2 000
holes and it takes about four and a half
hours to punch all these holes manually
so my student andre
who's leading this effort got frustrated
and he built this hole punching robot
from scratch
but we can also significantly enhance
the quality of hole punching as you can
tell by comparison
in this image so we also automate uh
fluid handling tasks in our model
systems
this is a robotic loading of hydrogel
cell mixture into the blood vessel
forming device
earlier so you can also automate uh
some of the key steps of cell culture
like media exchange so
these are systems automated systems are
making our lives easier
but what's more important exciting is
that using these
systems we're now able to really
drastically increase the amount of uh
data in vitro data we can extract from
these human cell
based model systems which i think is
unprecedented
we're very excited to further develop
this technology in the next
couple of years unfortunately i don't
have time to talk about
organoid on a chip technology but uh
in my life we're also developing micro
engineered platforms
for the purposes of culturing and
maintaining and also engineering
various types of organoids and again i'm
happy to tell you more about these
model systems offline if you're
interested just to summarize this is
what we do we actually
focus on developing microengineered
models of human physiological systems
healthy and disease to human
tissues and organs so i do not have time
to really go into this topic
today but in case you're interested in
learning about
learning more about what this technology
has to offer for direct discovery
i gave tedx talk five years ago about
this topic
and we also wrote a review article for
nature reviews drug discovery to talk
specifically about the potential of
organ chip
model systems for drug development
so finally uh this is my group and these
are
some of the collaborators we've worked
with uh and
these are funding sources so i'd like to
acknowledge their support
on some of the studies i talked about
today thank you very much for your
attention